welcome to the across the spoiliverse
podcast I'm your host Paul as usual give
them a real name now because we jumped
in quickly and I don't know who the hell
I was supposed to say I was so it's Paul
from heavy spoilers show for once joined
by Greg Alba from real rejects how's it
going Greg what's on the agenda today
well brother we got a lot on the agenda
today we're gonna talk box office we got
some big box office reports we got
Wonder Woman news we got Fantastic Four
and we got some strike news to talk
about but there's one very important
piece of information that I wanted to
convey to the audience before we move
forward at the time of uploading this it
is Paul's birthday ladies and gentlemen
and I wanted to say happy birthday to
Paul in all sincerity Paul has been an
amazing amazing friend to me over the
years uh we started talking randomly one
day when it came to like Godzilla versus
Kong just hitting him up and I feel like
ever since then we have talked
I think like every single day for like
many years unfortunately yeah
unfortunately fortunately for me
unfortunately for you and uh you've been
massive like you've been yes in terms of
like YouTube colleague and all that
you've been in a an insane help there's
certain things on my Channel that I have
absolutely like credit Paul for like
helping it really change the direction
and help change the business all around
but more than that you've been just like
one of my closest friends uh over the
past couple years and
like I have a lot of late nights where I
have a time difference or you're you
know you're eight hours ahead of me so a
lot of times if I'm working at like
midnight or 1am you're my friend I'm
talking to you at that hour all the time
and uh yeah it's it's been incredible so
to be able to do this with you I still
feel this need whenever we're on a
podcast because I admire your work so
much like everything I do is so like off
the dome but you're so research heavy
and you're so intelligent and articulate
that I even when I come on this show
with you I'm still I still got this like
thing in the back of my head it's like I
wanna I want to make a good impression
with Paul even though I'm like so
comfortable with you whenever we hit
record I have this thing in my heart
that's like make a good impression with
this guy because I admire you that much
my friend so uh that doesn't sound like
you do I do man sounds like you're
scared for yourself
he's got [__] on me he's got receipts on
me he could get me canceled at any
moment nah seriously you've been you've
been amazing for a happy birthday to you
man I hope you're able to enjoy it with
the family and the twinsies and um can't
wait to see you in UK one day one of
these days I will actually see you
physically in person it's so odd here
I'd have never seen you in person I'm
like no he's one of my closest friends
but yet I've never actually met you in
person
three foot tall 35 years young tomorrow
guys well today if you're watching this
so yeah I think I appreciate that Greg
I'm sure we've just lost all the viewers
now but I appreciate it now what I
clicked on here
well people love the negativity
apparently because I miss the negative
and work just say everything's rubbish
but we're going to start off with some
good news Greg what's uh what's the good
news this one the good news is that
we've got some crazy box office News man
David zazlov is having a hell of a day
because uh Barbie it's continuing to
dominate the box office it's ranking it
went up against the new releases with
the Meg 2 and Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles muted Mayhem and it came in
first again in his CR it passed the one
billion dollar Mark in 17 days that's
great first film to do that directed
solely by a woman yes for women and
Oppenheimer still holding really strong
um 552 million dollars worldwide
becoming known six films across the 500
million Mark and the Meg is actually
doing pretty well as well of meg2 what's
it at right now
um it 112 million dollars so like in the
states it's doing okay in the States but
overseas 112 million dollars is
co-produced by a Chinese company and I
feel like I think in China it's doing
extremely well and Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles while not being high we're gonna
go through all these in a second just
giving a quick little breakdown and
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles while just
debuting at number four out here it's
still got an A Cinema score there's not
too much competition coming out over the
next few weeks so it's expected that
even though it debuted you know like
mediocre it can have pretty good legs
specifically due to the word of mouth
and from everyone I know that's seen it
they they really they're very jovial
when it comes to talking about this
their experience with the film so all
around man yeah other than Haunted
Mansion every every film's looking
really good at the box office right now
yeah I thought it was okay
um I would say you know maybe seven or
eight I've stopped doing scores on my
reviews because one week I'll give like
a really bad movie in eight and then the
next week I'll give a really good movie
in eight and it's like where's the
where's the difference here mate you
know what I mean you're giving the flash
innate but then you're giving like John
Wick four and eight even though I think
I give it a nine but whatever and so
I've just stopped doing scores uh but I
did a video on it recently I enjoyed it
I felt like it was kind of across the
spider verse but with the adult jokes
stripped out of it now the awesome
adult jokes in there obviously that but
it's very clearly aimed at kids it's
very much like let's make it a movie for
kids
um rather than like let's try and hit up
both demographics and with adults and
children so like okay I mean it was all
right I am you know it's the start of a
franchise I kind of Batman Begins it a
bit at the end where it's like you know
quite a minor low-key villain for this
film and then they tease towards
something bigger coming down the line uh
they've got I think Paramount plus I've
got two seasons of a spin-off show
coming
um it's gonna sort of bridge the gap
between this movie and the sequel and
then they're gonna do a sequel and but
they the the way they set it up at the
end they kind of tease towards something
um if you know the expanded law of the
turtles and stuff then you're gonna
recognize some characters in the film
that tease towards some things coming in
the future uh and it was yeah I thought
it was enjoyable you know it's a good
start it's kind of doing around the same
numbers that spider Universe did like
the first one
um and I think over the next couple of
years once it gets the you know Seasons
out there and it starts to build an
audience that way then you know come
next time it could be an across the
spider-verse situation where you've got
a much bigger audience because they've
caught it on streaming same way into the
spider-verse kind of built an audience
on Netflix you know by the time the
second one rolled around everyone's like
yeah let's go see it so I think it's
going to be a similar sort of thing with
that but I don't think it's quite the
level that into the spider-verse was
obviously that got the Oscar as well I
don't feel like this is going to get the
Oscar in terms of anime they announced
already that it's going to be coming out
on digital in less than a month it's
coming out with September 5th if I'm not
mistaken yeah it's kind of odd that they
announced that [__] it's opening weekend
like opening weekend it's coming out in
like three weeks on digital it's really
odd to me that they do that well well it
they're doing it with the um last Voyage
of the Demeter the Demeter you know the
Dracula story
um that that's yeah that's coming out on
the 11th of August and they've already
announced that it's like 17th of
September is going to be its digital
release date and it's like why I was
gonna rush out and see it saw that and
thought I'll wait I'll wait I'll wait
guys
um so yeah strange tactics you know in
Hollywood I I feel like a lot of the
time they don't really know what they're
doing and when they do get a big success
like Barbie and Oppenheimer
they kind of get why but they can't
fully grasp exactly what's happened and
it was more kind of like a fluke or luck
or you know they weren't expecting it to
be that big and it turned out and it I
don't feel like they have a massive
grasp on the situation of why things do
well and why certain things don't
um but brilliant for Barbie I mean
passing a billion
that's uh that's absolutely incredible
I'm gonna take another L I'm gonna be
taking L's every week because I I said I
thought it would do okay but you know
even even the opening predictions I'm
sure they were lower than it took they
were they were around about there was it
the 8200 million or I remember 70
getting thrown out there as well
yeah any
even um something like Oppenheimer that
was predicted to do like
it's okay but I was reading the other
day that it's it's getting like 10
million dollars a day like clockwork
every single day so yeah it's it's crazy
that both these things have done this
well
um you know I it's a good good move for
them I'm glad to see that you know it
shows Cinemas out there and it's alive
and it's not just fully reliant on
superhero movies I think you do need
these wins once in a while to show look
mate you can make other movies that are
good and people will go see this do you
think that it will start a a trend of
movies trying to help promote each other
the way how Barbie and Oppenheimer were
able to do it because that's kind of an
unprecedented thing that was definitely
generated by social media and then they
took great advantage of that and I think
they could really do that with other
films it's rare where you have two big
films competing with each other these
days on the on the exact same opening
weekend that's a brilliant strategy
because they're so different I haven't
seen Barbie yet I was away from comical
you know how it is and you're like ah
I'm too late to seeing it now might as
well just wait
um when it comes to coverage on the
channel and stuff so I was gonna see it
in the theaters but I was away for
Comic-Con no I'm just gonna wait to
cover it when it comes out on digital
but this is an insane strategy I I it
really paid off immensely and I I find
it incredible
yeah well you know Tom Cruise has kind
of been predicting this for a while I
think he he kind of tried to cash in on
the whole Oppenheimer and bombing Barbie
movement but even during the pandemic
when stuff started opening up again I
remember there was that video of him
going to see tenet
um and it was kind of him like showing
like look Cinema's alive and stuff and
so just him being there and doing these
sort of things I think he's realized
that the way to promote Cinema is to
have the Stars promoting other films and
kind of building up everything as an
event a reason to go to the cinema and
obviously Bob and Heim has kind of been
the the totalitarian so I try to use
fancy words on the podcast it doesn't
always work out all the time uh it's
it's kind of the the the first big
example we've had where you know
something's kind of really helped push
another movie and pushed itself
um and I think Tom Cruise kind of
realized that almost
um when he was going to see Turner and
obviously he did it just in the in the
lead-up to Barbie and Oppenheimer didn't
work out quite well
um in terms of what Paramount we're
doing but something's going on at the
studio because the the scheduling for
them this year has been terrible they've
always dropped their movies like around
a weird time I'm sure Dungeons and
Dragons came out like get a weird time
um and I think Turtles is one of theirs
as well
um and that yeah dropping that like the
the week after Bob and Heimer but in the
same week as the Meg 2 it's uh weird
weird thing to do
um they they kind of maybe should have
done that I personally thought around
the school holidays haunted mansions
another one where originally that was it
was the Marvels that was meant to be
dropping in that place uh but they
swapped the release date and that's why
the Marvels is coming out in November
but Haunted Mansion feel it feels weird
dropping that movie in July instead of
Halloween very strange
um and um the Disney earnings calls
coming up this week
um I think it's Thursday they're having
it don't feel like it's gonna do well
now as much as we crapper Warner
Brothers they actually had a really good
earnings call
um apparently they've increased their
direct sales by quite a lot they've I'm
not sure the exact black figures but
there was something like there were four
billion in the hole and they managed to
drop that down to 2 billion or something
no that might not be the right number
but it was basically there was a billion
a couple of billions that they were in
the hole and they managed to reduce that
by quite a lot zaslav
um to be fair the guy you know he has
came in and done what he wanted to do
which was reduce the debt
um have some success have some successes
but he also did some stupid comments as
well
um talking about like well since the
strikes have been going on we've saved a
hundred million dollars and it's like
yeah but every company yeah every now
you might not know this Greg but during
the pandemic
um pretty pretty Patel one of our
politicians she was uh when everyone was
in lockdown she was bragging out because
she was like the head of the home office
and she was handling like Law and Order
and she was bragging about how
shoplifting was down and it's like well
yeah because everything's closed you
idiot and it was that kind of situation
where he was saying like oh we've saved
loads of money because we're not having
to pay wages they say yeah mate every
single company in the world when they're
their their Workforce goes on strike
they save money from not paying them
it's a stupid thing to brag about a
strange way to try to spin a really
obvious narrative when you're trying to
talk to your investors and your
stockholders to be like look at all the
money we're saving I mean maybe they
want I feel like we'll dive a little bit
more into it but I am part of the camp
that does believe
this some of these Studios I imagine
didn't want to actually want the strike
to happen to save costs on things to use
it as an excuse to cancel all their
properties and whatnot
um but you know as long as on the
positive side of the news in this
section of the podcast Warner Brothers
has had a relatively decent year I mean
they even had I'm just remembering right
now that Evil Dead rise which did very
very well for them as well I feel like
there are two films that I've done it
remarkably well when it comes to Barbie
and evil that arrives with the two
movies they didn't anticipate would be
the box office behemoths that they
ultimately became I think they were
really counting on it seems like
everyone was counting on the flash and
every box office analyst was also
thinking the flash would do really well
but that's their I've just realized
Tom Cruise was used to promote the flash
exactly so Tom Cruise is like getting
ahead of everything promoting other
movies uh but yeah like you were saying
the The Flash that all of the DC movies
really to be honest they were predicted
to be the big tentpole things
um and that was actually another thing
that came from the earnings call they
were talking about how
they were going to kind of lean away
from tent poles and do more kind of
quality lower budget films
um and you know try and make the best
movies they could instead of doing just
these constant big massive things which
we've been saying for a while
um try and you know just don't spend
crate like 300 million dollars on a
movie because it's going to be very
difficult for it to even break even yeah
and if if it bombs which we've seen a
lot of big bombs this year
then it's kind of embarrassing for the
the whole company and yeah it's best to
not take that risk if you don't have I
think when the strikes are over every
Studio primarily Disney and Warner
Brothers obviously are going to be
re-examining how much they should spend
on superhero films uh in particular you
know because I'm aware that Warner
Brothers they even have a department
there Warner Brothers uh I forget which
company it specifically is but it's in
conjunction with the ones who produced
like it um you know the Pennywise films
and whatnot where they have their mid
budget films uh now blood Masters were
Universe generally partners are
Universal yeah but they like blumhouse
tends to be in the really low budget
range like 1 million to 10 million
dollars and and then Warner Brothers
they have a section where they have
their mid budget because they and that's
it's a new line new line yeah so they
want to have their films fall a little
bit more under that category where
they're not exactly low they're not
exactly High budget but they're they're
enough to make like a big splash of the
box office especially when it comes to
their horror films but I think when it
comes to superhero movies they're going
to be really re-examining how much I
should be throwing at it and I think
Post strike I feel like this partly of
why they wanted to do of why I imagine
Studios wanted to strike I mean yeah
they save costs like everyone is the way
it's a good neat way to spin it on the
calls as love uh but at the same time
you know I'm you're hearing about like
Bob Iger might want to cancel the live
action remake of Hunchback of Notre Dame
or Notre Dame Notre Dame whatever I
don't know how to pronounce it
that's how I've always said Notre Dame
so yeah I think this is going to be a
time for them to reevaluate and and I
keep saying it to go oh you know because
of the strike we got to cancel these
things
um because I I don't think they imagine
Barbie would be as huge of a film as it
ended up becoming and Oppenheimer also
is like
way bigger than like that that is such a
to me
what no I the Christopher Nolan name
there's there's like no director out
there I can't think of another director
who has as strong of a household name as
Christopher Nolan you know we we don't
really even have that celebrity anymore
a lot of people say like Tom Cruise is
the last big celebrity you know where
his name alone can sell box office
receipts but even Mission Impossible
debt Reckoning granted there's a lot of
things working against it right now
that's even underperforming based off of
what everyone thought it would do and
it's gonna it's not gonna even match
what Fallout did uh but Christopher
Nolan he's is there another director out
there where you slap his name on there I
know tenant didn't do well but that came
out during the pandemic and you know I I
had to travel like an hour to go watch
that movie so it wasn't really playing
anywhere but Nolan his name alone so you
know that's like a big conjunction with
it because I think even there's there's
something about Christopher Nolan that
I don't know if a lot of people really
noticed this but do you notice how all
his films have this what is the font for
his movies they all have that same kind
of font
and I think that is very purposeful it I
it started with Batman Begins and he
hasn't really changed the kind of font
that he uses in the trailers and the
marketing and and the titles for his
films and I and I think that's so
intentional to make people no this is a
Christopher Nolan joint and no other
director can pull off something like
this because someone else as I'm saying
this because someone else could have
probably directed Oppenheimer maybe even
made the exact same film
but because it's Christopher Nolan the
interest is much higher due to it that's
insane to me that there's like one
director who can pull that off
yeah but he wrote it as well
um but I know what you mean about the
fun every time Christopher Nolan film
ends it cuts to Black and then you get
the title in white writing across it
um but yeah it's I mean Studios have
lost a lot on superhero movies this year
there has been some things that I've
done all right like Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 it's done well but you know
it didn't break the billion
um
personally I feel it should ever know
where there's lots of discussions on
Twitter like oh well you know it's
Guardians of the Galaxy they're quite a
low-key sort of team but the way they've
been built up the last couple of years
and for it to be the third film in the
franchise as well I feel like you know
that should have broken a billion when
you look at the other superheroes that
have done it Captain Marvel for example
and there has been a couple of billion
dollar films in the MCU that
the with the right marketing you can
push for it
um black panther as well you know wasn't
a massive Hero at the time that was
their first film obviously you know
these movies also are building off the
hype between you know up to Infinity war
and end game and so on but for this to
be the third film
um I I feel like you know a movie like
that had a lot of potential to do it
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania was
introducing Kang didn't didn't do crazy
numbers and I think you know with the
The Flash
um they've just realized like
the the audience isn't there unless it's
a big thing you know the the way endgame
was sold that was the Super Bowl of the
entire
comic book movie
whole the whole thing was like the end
game is the big big event It's The End
Game of it
um and they realize like we're spending
far too much on these smaller um I think
with Charlemagne who said it and used
that metaphor of the the Super Bowl and
being what endgame was and then they're
using you know the same Budget on
Saturday morning League football or
something
um and it feels like that when you see
the budget for secret Invasion and stuff
I think they're gonna start to realize
like oh we have overspent on these
things and there's clearly money and
things like Barbie and Oppenheimer where
they've got lower budgets more
artistically driven and there's you know
they're taking a unique spin on things
so I think going forward they will pull
that back now in regards to superhero
movie two
the kind of movies that Barbie and
Oppenheimer are
AI cannot replicate those kind of movies
like an AI script cannot do that you
need yeah I'm going to be really taking
the stand here for that
um yeah like these are original I
haven't I mean I haven't seen Barbie but
every opinion I've heard about it
whether they like it or not definitely
has an original way of going about it
I've seen you know as Christopher Nolan
has a very specific voice as well
and if when you're hearing the talk
about Studios wanting to use AI for
their scripts and whatnot the films that
are breaking the box office right now
the ones that are doing phenomenal AI
cannot pull that [__] off AI will just
pull from other things and be these the
the the movies that feel like they're
being carbon copies or being too similar
to other movies they're the ones that
people are going yeah I've kind of seen
that before this feels generic
you need original voice you need those
voices when they're in the writing room
having that process of discovery the
true emotion behind it trying to do
something really unique
that's why you need your Riders that's
why you need original artists and not to
rely on AI for your screenplays and I
feel like
I I really hope so Studios realize this
is why the wga is really fighting for
something like this because
the films that are doing phenomenally
well have an original voice to them and
you're just not going to get that with
AI you won't
um so yeah
yeah
um so yeah next story Wonder Woman three
Gal Gadot has said
um they're kind of working on things
she's met with James and Peter saffron
and they're kind of figuring things out
now this is recorded
pre it would have been pre-strike
because
um obviously the marketing they they
can't actually sit and answer questions
in new interviews now so she was talking
about the Superman casting as well
um and this was before it it had been
formally announced which kind of puts it
back a couple of months now
what can I do going on the DC EU or DCU
plan again Greg do you think what do you
think is happening with Wonder Woman 3
because I've got a bit of a theory but
do you think it's wise to do Wonder
Woman three what are your thoughts
part of me I'm trying to think of how to
phrase this without it sounding messed
up
um because I heard I heard from the hot
oh I think it was the hot mic pot the
one with uh Jeff Snyder and John Roka
two people I actually know
that
is pretty much like a misunderstanding
from gal gadot's end that uh that they
that they discussed it
but it was more like well we want to
work the way how James Gunn has told
everyone we want to work together I even
said that to Henry Cavill you know and
Dwayne Johnson we want to work together
in the future
and
it and I'm wondering if that got
misunderstood but then there's also
other things because James Gunn hasn't
clarified this because it very well
could just be they're doing a Wonder
Woman three and Patty Jenkins just won't
be involved in it
I feel like though that
what I don't agree with is everyone who
suddenly came out on Twitter saying that
she's a horrible Wonder Woman for some
reason that's the only part of it that I
really don't agree with is people were
just coming out the woodwork like oh
she's terrible sucks terrible actress
what are you guys talking I thought I I
thought she was a great Wonder Woman
I think that they do have to do a clean
slate it would be bizarre as hell to me
if you're gonna get rid of our Batman
from that universe or Superman from that
universe and then uh I mean there's no
cyborg they're definitely going to get
rid of Ezra Miller
uh Jason Momoa seems like up in the air
uh I I he could be Lobo or not it would
to just do another Wonder Woman with Gal
Gadot as much as I like her
I think DC definitely needs to have
Clarity on what their universe is
ultimately shaping into and they need to
get rid of any type of confusion in
order to get this thing on track because
bottom line the dceu or whatever this
universe is outside of the Batman and
Joker it is it is a it is a failure I
like when you look at the box office it
is a failure and they need to I don't
think they should do it if this is the
case
um so yeah I personally don't think they
should do it and
it just doesn't make sense to me to
suddenly do Wonder Woman three
um yeah
yeah
so the way I read it were light enough
after thinking about it uh because do
you remember when James did that big
announcement video he talked about the
Wonder Woman Paradise last TV show or
something on HBO Max so the way I
thought it was going to be is that it's
kind of pre she's a producer you know
what I mean she's a producer on that and
that that's basically gonna set up the
new Wonder Woman it's gonna be so
prequel Diana in her early years you
know we we saw her as a child and then
we saw her as an adult but we didn't
really get that time in between which I
think would be the perfect place to cast
maybe a 20 year old Wonder Woman or
something or late teens and then have
her become the DCU Wonder Woman now they
might do something where gal gadot's
like reminiscent on the past sitting
going I remember when I was 20 years old
in human years but it was like a
thousand years on their mascara but
anyway just go back to another actress I
think they might do something like that
now I completely agree and we've talked
this point to death but I really do
think that they need to just reboot
everything and that is purely because
you know the the universe kind of feels
like a mess there's also lots of
different fans of different properties
like I'm a big Zack Snyder guy don't
hide it and but I also liked some of the
stuff that they did you know I like
James Gunn Suicide Squad
um and even though Zach wasn't connected
to things you know there were a lot of
people that were getting enthusiastic
about sort of where things were going
with the the Walter Hamada stuff
um that's kind of a swear word if you
say that on online on Twitter now but it
hit a point where Black Adam obviously
brought back Henry Cavill and then
people got invested in that universe and
then they're kind of resetting it and
giving it a James Gunn thing and people
are getting invested in that universe
but then there's a chance that he could
do a hard reboot and all this stuff in
the flash could be wiped clean and
you're getting you know you're getting
people invested in every single
iteration like when the snydercook came
back I thought you know we might not get
another sequel or something but we might
get an animated Universe spin-off or
something where we explore this and and
I'm invested in that but then you you
hit Black Adam and then you you set up
something with Henry cavillin people get
invested in that and it's kind of like I
think you just need a hard reset and
stop sort of bringing these elements
across from the past to kind of sort of
soft reboot things because at what point
do they just say we're not gonna work
because I believe if they don't hard
reboot it now they'll do do it in five
years
that's purely because I personally don't
think the Box off interest is there now
the last seven dceu projects
they've most of them are flopped and
none of them are really I don't I'm sure
I read somewhere that the last seven
hadn't passed 400 million dollars at the
box office now these are the ones that
are in their connected universe so it's
not Batman it's not Joker but I mean
Blue Beetle that's not gonna do well I
mean the the tracking for that's really
low so I mean that's eight flops in a
row right if Aquaman 2 does badly that's
gonna be nine flops in a row
it it doesn't set things up well for
Superman Legacy and say you know they
bring across things like Amanda Waller
or which we're not we know they're doing
um well they bring across like gal gadar
to be the Wonder Woman in that universe
it's still going to be connected to that
and then say Superman Legacy you know it
it's doing this thing where it's sort of
tied in with that Universe if that flops
that's like 10 flops in a row I'm sure
it'll do okay I don't think it's gonna
do bananas numbers I don't think the
studio is really expecting it too I
think they're kind of thinking well
we'll start off good and then we'll
slowly build it up like the MCU you
think Superman Legacy
I think it'll do okay I don't think it's
gonna make an insane amount of money in
that that's purely just stuff the plot
licks I've heard as well
um you know it's gonna be a James Gunn
movie so
I I'm sure it'll be well received I
think people don't enjoy it but I don't
know if it's gonna have that
complete General audience sweep and
that's just the character in general
unfortunately you know Superman
he he's the most famous superhero out
there but
there's a lot of the audience I feel
that in general don't find them that
relatable I really like him and but I
think there is very much a set of the
audience who haven't you know they
didn't grow up on the Christopher Reeves
movies they might not have been attached
to Henry Cavill and this kind of that
audience that you need to win round and
get on board now being wrong in the past
again with Bobby but like at what point
do they if stuff goes badly or doesn't
hit a certain amount at what point did
the reset because let's bear in mind
this is Warner Brothers who I know you
said the the DC eu's been a failure but
Man of Steel did all right did pretty
well Batman v Superman did pretty like
did good didn't hit the billion but it
didn't run off the last um yeah
Suicide Squad the first one not well
received but it did good numbers but
that it so it made money but they were
still panicking over that now we're
seven movies in about to be eight that
have all flopped and it doesn't seem
like they're like realizing it I don't
get why they realized it back then and
thought that was bad and we have to
reset and now with this I like now let's
let's bring across Wonder Woman and do
whatever so it is weird and I think if
they might have to reset very soon
anyway if stuff keeps bombing because at
what point we're very close to being
eight flops in a row and if Aquaman 2
you know might do well might not but if
it doesn't then that's nine in a row at
what point do you be like
come on guys the writings on the wall
like
could it just diffuse do you want wonder
do you do you want Gal Gadot to continue
I'm I'm I I must have missed that you
know all right I don't think she should
I think I've always been in the camp
they should hard reset or I've always
said they should and just for the fact
that Batman and Joker as well just what
they've managed to do by not being
connected to this thing I think trying
to tie it in is the wrong way to go
about it and you know
you might disagree with my opinion but
the the numbers are there I think to at
least give people like there's a there's
a red flag there somewhere where you
know the the general audience isn't
connecting with this universe and even
to have loose strands connected to it
like we were sold that the flash was
going to be a big reset of the universe
I don't know if it is at the moment
because Aquaman's still in it and it
seems if garganot gets brought across
then I don't know yeah so yeah results
is the name of the game and I think a a
hard reset is what's in order and this
is coming from someone who really I like
most of the DC films that have come out
I there's there's a couple of them I
really didn't like but most of them I I
I the ones you listed at the beginning
I'm a big defender of I love the Snyder
films
um and I I even like birds of prey and
that's the number one movie that people
crap on and I I like that one too so
yeah I like the DC films for the most
part but clearly the way it registers
with audiences there needs to be a
change and I think with the Superman
Legacy I feel like the whole box office
is going to be extremely dependent
on that very first trailer because it's
really easy yeah to do a trailer for The
the new Superman
to make you go wow this feels like
traditional Superman but but just
feeling like traditional Superman might
register as this doesn't feel all that
different or original so if there is a
way to convey to the audience that this
can be something compelling something
different and unique yet also the
Superman that you love there's a way to
convey that in two to three minutes then
I think that can determine what the box
office will ultimately be as I know Man
of Steel didn't quite reach the numbers
that they were hoping for but there was
a lot uh aiding in it with its marketing
you know Zack Snyder coming over
Christopher Nolan producing it coming
off of The Dark Knight
um you know there was and also it had a
very different look and aesthetic to it
as well so they were at least conveying
that this is going to be a different
kind of Superman and the people behind
it and this is going to be really
reliant on James Gunn uh you know his
name attached to it in the start of the
new DC Universe but still that first
trailer I think is going to be the end
I'll be all for it like a second trailer
always helps yeah but first impression
is everything when it comes down to this
but we got other casting stuff that we
could talk about that seems confirmed it
seems confirmed for our favorite family
in the Marvel Universe for Fantastic
Four do you want to talk about it
Paulson
yeah so uh Vanessa Kirby is apparently
gonna be Sue store uh I mean that's the
worst kept secret in Hollywood right now
because I mean
I heard that a while back and then they
kind of just threw Margot Robbie in
there to sort of dance about with it um
and that kind of sucked all the wind out
the room uh but
I keep saying Circle it sucked all the
air out the room isn't that say every
week and then I have I listen back I'm
like oh what an idiot I sound like one
of those European guys that gets all the
catchphrases right but yeah Paul has a
British accent he must be right that's
what I do
yeah you must be intelligent um so yeah
I think Vanessa Kirby would be great
obviously what we've been hearing is
that the movie is going to be centered
around Sue storm and she's gonna be the
lead
you know you you're gonna get if you
announce uh typically it's led by Reed
Richard if you if you announce that you
know you're gonna get some backlash
online
um but I was thinking about it and there
is a way they can do it so Reed Richards
is still the head of the Fantastic Four
but they they base it from Sue's
perspective of what that is so she's
kind of like you're grounded like
experiencing all these things and I've
been rereading the Jonathan Hickman run
spoilers for what happens in that run
we're not going to ruin the whole thing
but basically in it read Richards builds
something called the bridge which allows
him to look into the Multiverse and see
how problems were solved on other
universes for example the first thing he
does is he looks at the history of Civil
War and sees if there was a way to to
resolve that conflict peacefully
um and then he starts looking at all the
other problems and
this whole time he's not telling Sue
about it so she's just kind of being
like well he keeps disappearing from his
family and got disappearing and going to
his room for five hours a day and stuff
and then what happens is he sees
versions of himself and he realizes
these these strangers come forward and
they're like you're almost close to
figuring out really come come with us
and eventually they he realizes that
there's a council of reads that have
abandoned their family and they oversee
every problem in the Multiverse
and so
they kind of have planets where they
grow crops and just to feed planets that
don't have air they fight Intergalactic
threats there's if they come across like
a Doctor Doom version who's went insane
and he's going to destroy everything
they're basically lobotomize him and
have
a basement just full of Dr Dooms from
across the Multiverse all signing in a
row and it's very what cut what it boils
down to though is eventually that they
will say we had to leave our family to
come and do this and that's the the
choice you have to make do you want to
solve everything which has been your
goal the entire time
um but it'll cost you family so I think
from you know Susan's perspective I
think that would be just seeing him
constantly disappearing and then coming
back I think that would be quite an
interesting thing and then you could
kind of discover what Reid's actually
been up to
um but he is like Reed Richards a lot of
people don't realize they're just
associated with like the stretch powers
and stuff they just think oh it can
stretch his arm out in his todger and
stuff like that but what read is is like
he's like the smartest person in the
universe so that's what I always get
drawn towards and I think that's where
the real interesting stories come from
and they could kind of pair it like
what's it like being married to a man
like that
um I don't know if they will do that but
that's just just putting it out there so
people who yeah Sue is going to be the
main character they don't lose their
mind you know there is potential to do
things certain ways that keep things
interesting for both men and women so
yeah like Sue storm is not exactly God
in the greatest portrayals and live
action thus far where uh Reed Richards
is obviously the lead yeah so in the
Fantastic Four live action movies
whatever the opinions you have them I
actually like Rise of the Silver Surfer
that that was a reasonable entertaining
film
but even there even in that one uh you
know Jessica Alba Sue's storm is not the
greatest portrayal of Sue storm and I
think Vanessa Kirby is a solid pick uh
you know like Sue storm is a she's very
intelligent scientifically minded as
well
compassionate caring strong resilient
responsible
uh assertive and I think that with
everything we've seen of Vanessa Kirby I
haven't I haven't actually seen the
crown but but everyone's always sort of
told me about her performance there she
plays Princess Margaret if I'm not
mistaken is that she can bring a real
sensitive and nuanced portrayal to the
role and you know obviously her action
and work like Mission Impossible and
Hobbs and Shaw but anything I've ever
seen her in she can bring a lot of
complexity to there and she has this
Grace this sophistication about her and
more importantly you know with her
immediately throwing her into an
ensemble that she has to lead I think
she constantly is able to generate
amazing chemistry with whoever she's on
screen with she knows how to connect
with other actors so well which is a big
part of acting uh it sounds so obvious
but yet it's so important to when
describing who Sue's storm is so I feel
like she be she's an amazing pick for
Sue storm and she has a she has the look
too as well she also has got the look
for Sue storm do you have a Reed
Richards I heard Matt's name going
around and I I feel like Matt Smith
would be a good pick actually
I mean it might be too doctor who-ish
but I still feel like he'd be a good
pick
yeah I don't know I feel like Reed
Richards in my head like Krasinski is
pretty close
um but I don't know if that's because
I'm too attached to the secret Wars run
yeah
I just don't know with Matt Smith I
think Deb Patel whose name's been put
forward I think he's quite a good choice
um
I mean who else has been Adam Driver
kind of I see it of that I think
basically Reed Richards needs to be a
[__] and that's kind of what makes
him interesting strange
I feel like Matt Smith can totally call
it did you like him I suppose I mean
yeah Damon obviously yeah I don't know
why I'm getting drawn to Doctor Who I
mean Damon who is
Doctor Who and Damon in one song
I'm thinking Mobius as well you know
what I mean that's kind of yeah and I
just don't yeah I don't know if I read
Rich heads or readout no I I mean I'd
have to say you know the actors can pull
stuff off obviously you know Heath
Ledger famously no one wanted him as the
Joker no I wanted Ben Affleck as Batman
so I mean give the guy a chance that
they obviously know more than me uh if
he's good but I just I personally just
don't fully see misery
um but he might I throw my hat in the
ring man I feel like he can play off the
serious analytical intense side but also
be charismatic leader he's got the
experience with sci-fi with Doctor Who
as well he can play intelligent and
complex and there's something about his
physique too he's not his face not
really his like I I'll give you that
like he doesn't look like when I think
of Reed Richards I don't know the face
of Matt Smith is not something I I would
paste on to Reed Richards right it's not
fun yeah
but his actual physicality they're with
with uh you know the whole like not that
it needs to be this because it's a
superpower being super elastic and
whatnot but there's something about his
kind of lanky slender build that I do
think can fit with Reed Richards in some
way I I just love uh I love Matt Smith I
even like him in morbius so yeah he's my
favorite part of Morpheus oh [__] sorry
um Bill Skarsgard I don't I was looking
at it to see who did uh which studio
produced it Bill skars God popped up
didn't spring to mind initially as Reed
Richards but just in this picture he
looks a bit like Reed Richards so so
we'll give it to Bill scores God guys
who have decided we've just got loads of
actors and laid them out on the table
um Bill Hayden he's also in there as
well he looks slightly likely I would
love that I would love Bill Hayden yeah
so another thing that came from it was
um I mean if you are online on Twitter
on Friday it was Bloody just non-stop
Fantastic Four castings
um so Jack Quaid got announced as being
Johnny storm that came from the John
Roker podcast I think yeah
uh
uh Jack wait and then what happened was
Jack Quay denied it and said it's not me
he denied it within the hour
um and then I think Snyder got a text on
the stream saying that it was actually
Joseph Quinn so he got that from his
Source saying no it's actually Joseph
Quinn who's um Johnny Storm now people
have speculated
that what like what if you get the so he
apparently got the initials JQ and that
was well you know he went oh that's Jack
Wade but people have been like well why
did he why did he just say Jack Quaid
out of nowhere I mean if you got those
two initials you wouldn't you wouldn't
just think oh that's Jacques didn't say
on the podcast so what people start to
speculate Greg was that Jack Quaid is in
the cast already and that's why he read
it and then thought it was that and then
it was clarified to be Joseph Quinn now
Grace Randolph Saturday let's cut a
Saturday Greg Grace Randolph on Saturday
says that Jack Wade is cast in the movie
but he's not playing Johnny Storm
so people have started joining the dots
I'm talking about myself here we've
started joining the dots and thinking
well snide a sort of he obviously knew
that Jack Wade was in it got a text
saying Johnny Storm JQ and was like oh
Johnny Storm Jack Quaid no no no no
Joseph Quinn he said oh crap so they
they think that he kind of gave the game
away that um Jack waits in the movie
might not be true but yeah people have
been speculating that uh he could be a
part of it as well Josh from den of
nerds did a podcast recently talking
about it he thinks that he's gonna be
Nathaniel Richards
um who if you don't know
read Richard's son has the ability to
alter reality
start off as a mutant I don't think he's
a mutant anymore
um but he can just change things on a
whim and basically and what the theory
was that it's
a Franklin Richards he's going to be
young he's going to be a kid but what
happens in the comics here
um is that he just something says
someone says to him like what do you
want be what what do you want to be when
you grow older or something along those
lines and he thinks like what am I gonna
be when I'm older and then he just turns
into an adult because he hasn't got a
full grasp of his powers so whatever he
thinks just happens and people are
speculating that Jack Quaid is going to
be like the older version of Nathaniel
and he's gonna be a kid he's going to go
what will I be when I'm older and then
he's going to warp into that now that's
not based on any leaks that's just
everyone guessing but yeah Josh from
denim nerd said that I thought you know
what that would be a good thing because
Jack Wade could pull off the whole
Tom Hanks Big Thing I think
um but what we'll have to say
come on I hope not I was thinking
um Antonio Banderas you know he's
getting rumored to be comparable I was
thinking he'd make I think he'd be a
much better doctor doing query would be
a much better doctor relatable
now what does Reed Richards have Greg
he's got gray sideburns who else has
gray well not gray sideburns gray
temples
Zachary Levi has got great are you
transitioning the Zachary Levi news
so everyone's been getting canceled this
week everyone's been getting wait we
didn't even touch on the really quick I
I want to spend one minute on this
because I've seen backlash for Joseph
Quinn
um if I can just take 30 seconds to say
this I think that Joseph Quinn would be
a great Johnny Storm if he is that pick
uh who did he play in stranger things
again Paul
Eddie yes
um like when you think about Johnny
Storm as this impulsive jovial humorous
guy uh
uh Brave and loyal
confident flirtatious adventurous
emotional all these qualities of Johnny
Storm I think they're all representative
of just that one perform I don't think
he'd play Eddie you know obviously
Eddie's a little bit shunned and looked
down upon whereas Johnny Storm wouldn't
be uh I I feel like Joseph Quinn would
be a perfect pick for it maybe not the I
the look that I imagined but I I wanna I
wanna throw in my defense for for Joseph
Quinn it's just the 30 seconds I wanted
to do before yeah
Levi my hero my hero in the media it's
okay
we have some so uh yeah so we've ruined
the whole section there but uh Zachary
levite is everyone's in hot water this
week should we just start with Stephen
Amell because I try to do the Segway
totally [__] up I just had to defend
Joseph Quinn for a second I'm sorry Paul
so uh yeah we're getting to a point now
where the the strikes have obviously
started dragging out quite a bit and
because of that you know some actors are
getting frustrated with it now Arrow
star Stephen Amell
umstoday.com they've done a big story on
it they've said
Stephen amell's solidarity with sagathra
has come into question
um so he made an appearance at Galaxy
Con in North Carolina last Saturday and
spoke out against the Union's decision
to strike after several failed
negotiations he said I support my union
I do and I stand with them
however he said I do not support
striking I don't I think it's a
reductive negotiating tactic I find the
entire thing incredibly frustrating
and then he went on to say and I think
the thinking as it pertains to shows
like the show I'm on premiered last
night I think it's my big great promo
heels uh yeah so I just said that yeah
so yeah he did something he did like a
really weird Instagram video as well did
you see that where he was standing in
front of the billboard for heels and he
was just like like selfieing himself
which I don't know how else you sell for
yourself uh but he was standing like
going I just want I like my hard work or
something like that and he was just
showing off the billboard behind him but
one of the the stipulations with like
sag is you can't promote your work so
he's like clearly promoting his own work
standing filming himself
um in front of his billboard and showing
it off going I just appreciate doing my
hard work I just want my hard work what
do you think about the whole situation I
think Stephen and Mel
is definitely promoting his show first
off yeah even in that quote that was
going around he he might not say heal
season two but he says like the show
that I'm on that premiered last night
and you know he went on
his little Instagram rant and then he
even went on TMZ as well
and I I think like
yeah
especially with the timing of everything
now is not the time to be putting
yourself out there where you want to
cause any type of confusion because I
when I'm reading everything as I've read
everything he said and the the the
bottom line consensus that I feel like
he's trying to say
what I feel what I really feel like he's
trying to say I know the easy thing for
me to do would just be to just
completely [__] on him I still think
it's
it's idiotic and the way how he's gone
about it and he really shouldn't have
just said any of this especially right
now
I think what he's trying to say is yes
he does support the union Because he
believes in uh you know democracy
believes in the vote he really believes
in that and bottom line is everyone
voted for that so of course he's going
to support them he does wish though that
it didn't go down this path
because
uh he he feels like putting things to a
halt uh was not the the best solution to
it but regardless he's still gonna
support them at the same time though
as I was coming out of my mouth I was
going it's still very Contra he seems to
contradict himself a lot uh with being
like no here's what I'm trying to say
but at the same time he's not really I
think he sounds very hurt that he can't
promote his show that he worked very
hard on that this is coming out during
the time of the strike happened right
around the time he's supposed to promote
heal season two a show that he has
worked very hard for it and I think he
actually really injured himself working
on because it's a wrestling show and I
think he severely injured himself at one
point and it does really bother him but
everyone's affected by this who's not
able to promote this you know everyone
who has some something I'm sure the Blue
Beetle actors would love to be promoting
that to try to help it get more box
office revenue right now I'm sure
everyone who has a show coming out would
love to promote it and
you know I imagine what he is actually
saying and I guess the reason why I was
trying to give the slightest Slither of
a benefit of a doubt just the very
slightest little hole even though I'm
like nah dude what you're saying you
shouldn't be saying this right now you
sound very contradicting to yourselves
at the same time I do think he is
potentially saying something that a lot
of people are feeling
um who have their projects coming out
but that's part of the sacrifice and
that's part of being in unity that's
part of being in solidarity that's what
you sign up for here and so the best
thing you should do and the mature the
mature part in terms of standing in
solidarity especially when you are a
prolific actor right now who is in sag
that you should just be right now the
thing that you ought to be honing in on
with your with your when you're
vocalizing stuff is just the support
with uh your colleagues is your support
with everyone else so I don't think he
should be going out there
saying most of what he's saying even
though I feel like he's trying to have a
great conversation he's trying to have
it be multi-layered he's trying to have
it be nuanced
all that Nuance is gonna get lost you're
dealing with the rhetoric of people who
who love to clip out things and no one
really reads things in a nuanced way I'm
even trying to read things read this in
a nuanced way and I'm having a hard time
doing it right now because I'm like oh
you're a little contradictory because
you seem to constantly bring it back to
I don't believe that striking was the
way to go about it where what else what
other this this got to the point where
there was no other options left they had
to go on strike there was nothing else
left and there would be there's never a
good time to strike for anyone and I I
could get the there's I think the way to
phrase it just plain and simple would
have been
I wish I could promote what I want to
promote right now
unfortunately we have a strike happening
and I have to support that strike and I
have to stand by my fellow actors as
well so I can't talk about those things
as much as I'd love to talk about those
those things I can't because I we are on
strike and I have to show my support
there that's how we probably should have
phrased it instead of the way he's been
going about it I feel like he's not
communicating this well at all and he
probably should have just ended it with
that Instagram long thread that he put
out instead of going on TMZ trying to
clarify because I think he just made
things worse for himself
yeah I think um in situations like this
you know you have to take the good with
the bad if you're enjoying being in a
union where you get benefits because of
it
um you you have someone to turn to for
advice and stuff if they go on strike
you know you even if you disagree with
that you've just gotta bite you you bite
your tongue
um and you've got to take the good with
the bad you know it can't always be in
your favor if you're part of a union you
don't if you have individualistic needs
and wants then don't join a union
because
a Union's entire thing is about people
United as one whole instead of just one
person and so maybe you know if you
don't want that whole Union mentality
then don't join the union because this
is you know you're gonna have to
sacrifice some stuff if people go on
strike
um and that's probably gonna happen at
some point in in a Union's history
unless they get everything their way and
yes I thought just a stupid thing to say
I think in situations like this the the
only thing that even if you disagree you
should just say something like I hope
everyone gets treated fairly and I'd
love to live in a world where everyone
gets paid fairly
um and that's all you have to say I mean
if a24 who agreed to all the terms that
the the strikers put forward the unions
put forward if they can agree to it why
can't Disney and Warner Brothers and
stuff like that why can't they agree to
the terms they've got way more money
um and it's just something's going on
here that makes the the studios look
very greedy in my eyes and having actors
like this as well come out and say they
don't support striking and
it's just kind of like well yeah you
have to unfortunately you're gonna have
to do it otherwise leave the union if
you don't support one of the main things
then you can't just have all the
benefits of being in a union every
single thing on Earth has pros and cons
to it no matter what it is if you join a
union and they go on strike guess what
you you're on strike yeah
um and yeah I think you just need to
just go off on your own mate if you if
you don't I think like which you won't
do because you know the unions benefit
you too much I think that one of the
dumbest things he said was what he ended
it off with of saying that this strike
is this whole Pro the process of going
about it is myopic
you know
um essentially implying that you know
the the process of the strength or
focusing too much on the here and now
without thinking about the future or the
bigger picture of things
and then would this what is obviously
this
this need that he has to promote heal
season two
that is him being my that he's being
myopic about it he's focused so much on
ah I really want to promote this right
now which I understand I can understand
the pain of of that like I can that is
one part of it where I can totally get
because you work you spend so much time
working on a show and you and to finally
come out as your one-time promoted and
you can't do it when it's about to
Premiere and he probably feels that the
whole responsibility of heels doing well
falls on his shoulders because he's the
biggest name attached to it sure I get
that
at the same time the myopic part about
it on his end is he's too focused on the
Here and Now for him instead of the
bigger picture for what the SAG strike
is ultimately about and what It
ultimately represents which is an end
game battle that is the big that's the
real bigger picture which he also stands
to greatly benefit from as well if sag
can ultimately get what they want uh you
know even with something like you know
with his residuals for [__] like arrow
and whatever you know or heels is honest
I think it does go onto a stream I'm not
sure about that but all his appearances
in the arrowverse like dude your checks
will get a whole lot better right now if
they if you guys can get the residuals
that you want I I watched all of Arrow
and I watched it all on Netflix and so
yeah I think that I think that he was
he's not being smart about this and
every time I try to be like what's he
really trying to say
he just says something that I'm like ah
dude now you're you're shooting yourself
in the foot man stop you can dial it
back dial it back
I don't think of Zachary Levi said
Zachary Levi said one sentence that got
like he said Zachary Levi
uh is a bit of a I know we're going to
go into that and I think Zachary Levi is
already has a Target on his back at any
given moment in some ways he's kind of
like
he's kind of like
I liken it sort of to Chris Pratt in a
sense of people already got so many
issues with the guy that it just takes
one little thing for him to say to
really hear because I don't think what
he said is is drastically egregious as
what um Stephen Amell said it was still
stupid what he said don't get me wrong
it was an idiotic thing for him to say
um but he's also you know really
vehemently supported the strike uh prior
to the state it seemed like there was
just one part of it that he said
something done but yeah
so I seen someone on Twitter say that
Zachary Levi is who people think Chris
price yeah yeah but I mean we'll get
into what his comments were so so just
going back to heels and what you said
about it being myopic yeah completely
agree you know heal season two people
might not talk about it this time next
year but the stuff that's happening with
the strikes is going to benefit people
for decades so yeah maybe just stand in
solidarity with them please Stephen
um you've seen the backlash you've got
hopefully that's helped you to
understand why people are annoyed at
your comments and you might come in and
be like like we get we say stupid stuff
all the time Greg in the moment and then
someone will be like oh you've been a
bit of a [__] there mate and I'll go
you know you know what I think I might
be being a bit of a [__] we don't we
don't go on TMZ and double down to be
fair but we're like uh you may have a
point there uh so yeah hopefully you
just realizes this um I actually read
somewhere that the entire cast of Arrow
is set to join the picket line on
Saturday and they're kind of wondering
like will Stephen Amell show up
um so yeah we'll see what happens with
that but
okay yeah I guess we're gonna see so
Zachary Levi's comments on the strike
the guy uh so he went to Comic-Con
Manchester just just down the road
um and the 42 year old I don't know why
it says his age the 42 year old actor
told the crowd I'm not allowed to talk
about this is so dumb I'm not allowed to
talk about any of my previous work I'm
not allowed to talk about movies that
are maybe a superhero in I'm not allowed
to talk about TV shows that I may have
been in there who worked at Best Buy in
I'm not allowed to talk about any
animated princess movies that I was
fantastic in as the best Prince ever I'm
not allowed to talk about those things
and he got really angry and punched
someone in the face
um so what I I did read it and was like
uh I kind of see his point but
I actually had to explain to me going
back to that whole thing with Stephen
Amell we learn and we grow so the way
that it got explained to me was well
Chris Pratt s even I'm calling Chris
Pratt Zachary Levi him saying I was a
prince in something people might go and
Google uzakra Levi Prince movie animated
they then get the name of the film and
they go and watch it on a streaming
service now that pays the studio who are
withholding wages from the actors so
even him doing that could make someone
you know say a hundred people see that
and they go Google what that movie is
and then
give they they inadvertently give money
to the studio which the the unions are
trying to combat right now which makes
sense
um and that's why the whole promotion
thing isn't happening you know it
because the money's going to people that
are exploiting workers
um so the thing about both these
comments is that they said it at an
event and I know Stephen Amell was like
the those comments weren't meant to be
public and it's like well why did you
you say them in public but to be fair I
think when you're on a mic and you're
just kind of improvising like we say
stupid [__] all the time again
um I don't think he completely thought
of the ramifications of it and I think
in the moment he was just kind of
explaining I'm not allowed to talk about
this thing I'm not allowed to talk about
this thing you know he's entertaining A
Crowd
should he have said it uh probably not
um
but
I I think what's rubbing people the
wrong way is him saying it's the worst
part that's all I have to not say no
yeah yeah
yeah
we just said I'm not allowed to talk
about this I'm not allowed to talk about
this can we talk about this
um but it doesn't really seem like he's
going against the strike itself
he's he's kind of like where is Stephen
Amell sort of saying he doesn't agree
with striking
it feels like Zachary Levi is not
necessarily going against the strike
yeah but it did kind of turn out to be a
bit of a that should storm I think with
Zach Levi I mean it's really obvious
with Zachary Levi's talking about and
I'm I mean I think the guy's a little
crazy don't get me wrong like I totally
get what what people have to say about
the guy he seems a little bit nutty
um it seems like he's really
specifically just talking about the
whole
even he even had like a he tried to
clarify what he meant and he has been
outspoken for the prior to this he has
he has really thrown his hat in in the
ring for the support for the wga in sag
um
I think he's talked when he's saying
this is so dumb I I felt at least when I
watched the clip it seemed to me my into
my personal interpretation about it was
this thing that is very confusing for
people who are still celebrities who are
attending these fan events who are there
yeah based off of their work that is why
they are there you know I I just my our
one of our buddies koijandro he's just
hosted Fan Expo where there was
before Stephen Amell was there and then
you know there's there's all these other
celebrities who are there but they can't
talk about any of their work but yet
that's what the fans paid for initially
prior to the strike to show up for to
engage with them on and they can't talk
about any of it so part of it does seem
a little silly when you think about it
right of I'm I'm here but I can't what
am I supposed to talk about if when I
can't talk about anything that you guys
actually showed up here initially to
hear me talk about I can't touch on any
of those subjects
the problem is again the communication
the phrasing of those things trying to
make levity and try to make humor out of
the situation while engaging with your
audience while trying to bring us a
level of self-awareness
he ended up saying something in front
like trying to bring trying to be funny
at the same time he ended up saying
something stupid yeah you know he ended
up saying this is so dumb and I'm like
well dude no you're
you're more than likely going to get the
text of what you're saying is going to
spread more than the video of you saying
and the video of you will spread and
I'll still look bad you know
um but just reading it sound like if I
when I first read it before seeing the
video it sounded significantly worse to
me just reading it and he did try to
clarify it you know uh you know again so
in the whole thing of like yes this is
all necessary the strike is necessary
and all that and then he did go on to
basically speak about but we also cannot
forget our fans during the strike fans
that spend their money and energy
traveling far distances to talk about
with our talk with us about our work
that means so much to them we should be
able to engage our business exists and
succeeds because of the fans and I think
it's imperative we appreciate them for
their support of our careers so it
seemed like he was a bit uh at odds with
himself
during The Fan event which I'm sure
again I'm like I I can imagine a lot of
people who are attending these fan
events these celebrities are also
feeling that so you got to be extra
careful about your approach and how to
talk about things it's as simple as and
I think it's just as simple as saying
there's so much I would love to talk
with you guys about but I gotta stand in
solidarity and we have a strike going on
so I can and I hope you can understand
that it's it's that simple that simple
but
yeah when when before when you said
um what do the actors talk about these
events I personally think that would be
the perfect place to talk about the
strike and you know what you're fighting
for and why you're on strike and explain
that because it's such a Hot Topic as
well like we even just us diving into it
our most popular episodes have been
where we've talked about the strike so
yeah there's obviously interest around
it I think I think I think it was just a
communication issue and it's probably
his personality where he wants to be an
Entertainer
um
like there's touchy subjects that you
kind of have to be very careful about
um and he's obviously you know he's
known for his comedy and if you're
standing up on stage like that you're
probably trying to be entertaining
rather than dower but
uh yeah I think you could have just
talked about the strike and what
Hollywood are doing and why it's not
fair to the actors like seemingly has
just come out
um I'll get the quote up in just a bit
um but there's actually been a lot of
development whilst we've been doing the
this episode
um now there's not like major things you
know not then it's not going to change
the the outcome I don't think um but
just more people standing in solidarity
so yeah CMO said well people often don't
understand is your average sag actor
isn't a lead on a TV show Making
whatever amount of money per year
they're really going to get they're
really going gig to Gig and struggling
and we need to make sure the industry
conditions are such that they don't get
exploited
um so yeah that's kind of what I think
what Zachary Levi should have said
something along those lines
um and yeah there's also been a post
about Netflix career so Netflix
apparently does not give any residuals
to South Korean actors for their shows
supporting actors pay for these Netflix
shows yeah supporting actor pay for
these Netflix shows starts at 300 per
episode the president of Korea's actors
Union has sent several messages to
Netflix and has gotten no response and
that's from the LA times so I mean if
you think about those Korean shows as
well of the Netflix ones especially Greg
every time one comes out I end up
covering it because it's just you the
the amount of exposure and the views
that they get
and for I mean squid games their biggest
show ever and that's crazy
uh it's sort of like its own squid game
when you look at it because the bloody
exploiting everyone from career and just
uh making a table a little bit and then
the awesome making their own real life
version of squid game without noticing
any of the irony so well done there
Netflix
um yeah so what I feel in general is
that you know I wasn't completely like I
I'll be honest with you guys you know
the most ignorant ones of you out there
you you pieces of crap I was probably
worse than you in terms of ignorance
about what this Whole sag thing was
obviously I knew about actors I had
um but I didn't understand the whole
residual things
um I didn't understand like what
streaming was taking away from actors
and for example say a season of Cheers
people are still making money off that
because it's still getting shown in
reruns and stuff whereas something I got
made last month people aren't making
money from that because it's on a
streaming service and stuff like that I
just didn't didn't understand the whole
thing and I think what this has really
brought to light and what the publicity
has done to kind of get it's given a
really negative light to Hollywood I
feel just them dragging out the strikes
in general it's allowing a lot more
actors to show how bad residuals are and
I think if they don't agree to the the
demands there's going to be a lot of big
actors who just flat out refuse to sign
on onto streaming movies and streaming
shows because they're gonna think well I
could go work at HBO and do a TV show
and I'll probably still be getting paid
for the next couple of years whereas if
I do a streaming show you know if the
front end cost isn't that good
then I'm not gonna bother doing it
because there's no back end money coming
in there's been so many actors that have
come out and said you know when I was
working as a waiter or something and I
got a part-time job on a TV show when I
couldn't afford stuff you know that
residual check sometimes arriving at the
door it helped me through the week and
that's not the case anymore and I think
it's just Sean Hollywood in such a bad
greedy light and again
we're having this whole thing with Bob
Iger who we're gonna use on the
thumbnail and because I feel like he's
really becoming the face of Hollywood at
the moment where it's Disney or the big
conglomerate they're they're PR they're
saying they can't pay these actors but
they're getting so much in bonuses
they're at billionaire weekend clubs
spending insane amounts of budgets green
lighting things like Haunted Mansion
having so many flops in a row
you know all the all the Marvel shows
I'm gonna be honest with you Greg you
know as much as we crap on them like oh
is Marvel dead as Disney lost has Kevin
feige lost his touch I don't feel like
Kevin feige was desperate to do Disney
Plus shows I think what happened was Bob
Iger came in and was like look mate
we're launching a streaming service
Marvel is a big property you better
start making TV shows for it and you
better make them bloody good
um and I feel like he's just kind of
forced feige into doing lots of
different TV shows and it's all out of
greed we talk about this every week how
greed is just such a damaging thing
um the studios could easily pick I saw a
figure saying that it's gonna it would
cost 20 million
um to meet the actor demands that's how
much it would cost the studios and you
think about the amount of money that
they throw away and burn and give people
them bonuses
uh that that's one Bob Iger a year prior
to bonuses to support an industry of uh
000 or 600 000 whatever people it's
crazy
um and I think that this is like uh from
an outside point of view do you think
this is looking good for the studios or
do you think it's looking bad for
were you just brought up I mean it's a
good it's a good point because it seems
like whenever it comes to
The Working Man
it's and wanting them and them wanting
to be paid more fair
it becomes an issue a financial issue
yet these CEOs and whatnot can
constantly write themselves like
ludicrous bonus checks uh every quarter
or at the end of the year or something
like they they gladly pay themselves
significantly more uh and I this is this
entire thing has been exposing the the
ugliness of it because at the end of the
day
they need to sag wga
they need to work with the studios and
the studios they need to work with them
as well
and if you are the boss
it's so hard for you guys to look like
you're the victim in this situation that
you are
that you're being treated poorly or
something like that you know it
everything about this is just exposed
into it even zaslov when he was doing
the the meeting recently and he he
expressed this whole sentiment
about how we were hoping this ends by
Fall I think he was saying like we were
hoping this all Ends by Fall yeah
September I hope this ends by September
uh we we want to make sure that they
feel they are paid fairly we are in the
business of Storytelling I'm I'm just
going off memory here I'm not quoting
exactly but he was he was saying all
this he was basically saying all that
but then the big part is it wasn't him
who said it I think I think might have
been the CFO who said it that they
managed to save uh just shy of like a
hundred million dollars which we were
talking about earlier
and that's the takeaway right there does
it like everything that you were trying
to say is oslov with trying to say the
right things like like when he was
giving that commencement speech and
trying to say the right things but then
the crowd was booing him and chanting
against him
this is another example of that like
yeah you're taking the different path
than what Bob Iger said smart to do that
but then you have your the CFO saying
the 100 million dollar thing which again
is like oh look at them
they're now trying to express how the
strike has been beneficial for them and
how this is a good thing that they are
not paying that it's like it all circles
back to the greed of what you're talking
about or all circles back to you guys
are now saying that these things that
they are be everyone is that these camps
are now unemployed right now that they
are struggling a lot of them are
protesting out in the heat
every single day trying to fight for
what's right for being treated unfairly
them being treated unfairly has allowed
you guys to now benefit financially even
more trying to even even though that is
the word myopic that is a very myopic
way of thinking about it because that is
the right now down the road you can eat
those screenplays you need those actors
on set you need all that or so I'm not
going to generate any of those profits
so you're trying to make a neat spin on
it right now but bottom line the message
that is now being conveyed is we are
benefiting from this and then there's
even those reports coming out I don't
have any of it in front of me right now
but I just remembered how there was
reports coming out which I feel like
they intentionally leaked to try to
scare you know of the of like Netflix
hiring an AI consultant for nearly a
billion dollars or something like that
you know and even though it was saying
it was more about algorithmic measures
and try to help make business decisions
on what kind of direction to take the
movies and Studios or what to focus on
but it's more based off that still just
it getting out there is a headline of
them hiring AI experts and throwing down
instead of paying their writers and
actors are willing to match that will in
a match what they're asking for they're
now hiring AI experts and paying them
hundreds of millions of dollars instead
of paying their writers and actors it's
just it's Insanity what they're doing
they're being [__] about it
and it does show the utter disregard
that they have for the uh how essential
these people are so I think they look at
it as
I don't even know exactly how they look
at it man like they're the amptp and
there's only a few people in their
position so they get the big fancy
checks while they have you know when
they there's a there's only a few of
them and
a hundred something thousand of the
actors you know there's only a few of
them and thousands of writers so
probably just look at them
I've I've worked at places where like
I've asked for equipment or another
member of staffs asked for equipment
like say like oh I need a new laptop my
other one's broke they're like oh what
ones you need to be like oh I need like
this three thousand pound one and then
I've asked for like a pay rise of a
thousand pound a year and then what no
no we can't we can't do that we can't
it's like mate like the the laptop is as
important as I am to this job you know I
mean like my and all like I don't I'm
gonna brag but like so all my members of
staff that work for me now have had at
least two pay rises in less than two
years and it's purely because
um you know the business is doing well I
and I don't want them to become
resentful and being like
and we are in a cost of living crisis as
well and I I personally believe that if
people are comfortable financially
they're not stressing about bills all
the time
um and they're they actually see
themselves getting rewarded that they'll
work better I just and I because I've
worked it in places where I've been
treated like that and it's really helped
and I've worked in places where it's
been like
are kind of we've taken away your
Saturday night shift because we just
can't afford to pay this and it's made
me stress out because I've lost that
money and I I just think in general like
that Hollywood's just shooting
themselves in the foot because there's
going to be so many disgruntled people
that return pissed off
undervalued demoralized I mean look at
this thing now how many generations is
this gonna set back who wanted to come
into this industry that now just think
I'll just go be a [__] YouTuber
instead because I'm not gonna make money
as a famous actor or a screenwriter and
I think they're just they shoot
themselves in the foot constantly just
because of greed and because it's like
oh they could do it they they know they
could do it they're gonna have to do it
eventually because that industry can't
survive without these people out there
you know brushing to the side the fact
is that all these execs and stuff 100
rely on the actors and writers you take
away 10 execs from a company
nothing's going to change really you
know minor things will change some
projects might not get greenlit you take
away all the actors and writers from
Hollywood the industry is completely
booked it's the same as if you took away
all the cameraman
you know all the the Gap up the best
boys if you take away as
a certain segment of it you completely
[__] and for the amount that the execs
get paid
well I mean we went to the the wage list
recently and you know zazlab was getting
like half a billion
I go was like 25 million per year think
about how many people to ages that
covers
I mean could I could do with one less
million a year
could could we move them on to 24
million a year could we move Bob Iger
down to you know instead of half a
billion moving down to 400 million is he
gonna really see the difference there
um and I I personally don't think you
would and I think it would make so much
of a difference to other people's lives
it's a thriving industry it's based on
creativity you know people
often do their best work when they're
not worried about money and constantly
stressed out all the time you know
they'll welcome some things that that
arise from those situations but I think
just looking after people who you rely
on is a very important thing to do as a
boss and I think if you don't you I mean
the amount of companies I've worked at
where
that there's been say a team of 30 or
something and like when I worked in a
call center and they just treated
everyone like [__] even like the like we
were all part of like the top five team
always got put on the big projects
because we're like oh these guys can
sell they do re they always bring the
money and they always get the
completions
us we will ask for a pay rise now what
now said that we can't afford it all of
us left at the same time and the company
ended up shutting its doors like six
months later because
it will hit a point where you've pissed
off so many people in the organization
that they just leave
um and I think yeah they just need to
treat people better I think it's gonna
going to cause so many issues down the
line that could easily be avoided and
they are going to have to negotiate at
some point so why are you dragging your
heels and making this gun for longer
where people are going to end up not
people are losing out on months of work
just they should just go to the
negotiations straight away and we did
here on Friday that they were going to
work on it they were going back to the
table with the writers but from it's
stalled again and it's just it's
dragging people out and you know they
made that comment about how they're
going to wait until the writers are
losing their homes and stuff and it's
just uh yeah it's not it's not a good
way to treat people people are gonna get
deep Greg
everything we know about the universe
tells us that we're the only form of
life in the entire
thing
[Music]
999.99999
of the universe's devoid of life and the
one planet we know about for definite
that has life on it everyone treats life
like it's a piece of [__] don't look out
for each other aren't nice [__]
constantly trying to screw each other
over just just try try and be nice mate
yeah we've always we're all we've got so
if you can be nice to someone just
please try and do it love and cooperate
man
and that's why I get 10 minute birthday
intros at the start of episodes and it's
met yeah happy birthday Paul
yes
so yeah any final words Greg final final
words no I just hope you have a great
birthday and I hope that your wife and
children are you gonna be hanging out
with them are you gonna go do your own
thing
okay yeah I'm technically all right man
got Mt doing a video across the spider
verse uh so yeah he's thank God Mt came
along when he did because uh he's helped
me out a great Bunch actually managed to
step back from the channel and take some
time off with you I messaged you about
MTS Guardians video that is he is it was
great like I was I was like 17 minutes
into it Paul this is an amazing video
um yeah it's annoying because he's he
started doing um scripts for the the
editors as well where he's been putting
in assets because normally I'll get like
a message saying like pull this a really
obscure comic your reference what the
hell are you talking about and I'll be
like oh just go find it go find it I'll
I'll have to sit and dig it out but he's
like made a whole document with every
single thing that I was talking about
and uh
I checked on slack today in all the
editors were like empty the gold
yeah he's making me look bad phenomenal
I mean I've always I loved it it's great
I loved his work when he was when he was
formerly pardon you rock stars thought
it was amazing
um but not to see him over here he seems
even more in his element honestly uh it
seems more complicated yeah his
he's across the spider-verse video is
really good as well so guys keep an eye
out for that that'll be dropping uh soon
and before you know it Mt you'll be the
only host on the channel because uh you
have taken over and made me look really
bad and I'll be like
just want to do my podcast with Greg
full-time these days
yeah but thanks a lot guys again
um make sure you subscribe to Greg real
rejects I think guys do there's a lot of
uh a lot of controversy in the reaction
community at the moment people saying
people don't react harder tell you what
Greg always puts 100 effort into
transforming it
would you yeah he is you know genuinely
when you watch his videos you can tell
the guy is actually like not just
sitting there playing someone else's
video to get views put start in add so
much to it and yeah go check out real
rejects if you haven't already I'm sure
you have like these guys have been about
forever and there's a reason for that
it's because they're so damn good I
think the channel is better than what it
was a few years ago every video takes
many hours to edit and there was a time
where it didn't take yet much time to
edit for now every video takes a long
time and there's a reason for that yeah
no you can tell
well yeah there's all I mean there's
always been that controversy in the
reaction community and I know you aren't
someone who there's two ways you can
look at everything and be like oh [__]
those guys saying I'm not putting enough
effort in and you went the other way and
were like we're gonna put in we're gonna
make people realize why reaction content
is actually good and why need it it has
a place on YouTube so we're not just
gonna
[__] about appreciate it so I mean you
don't really get any comments not really
no I mean I think I because we also
especially with do more movie stuff and
more movies and shows and we're less
like yeah you don't really do trailers
that often they see that where
there's so much we're like reviewing it
as we're watching it like it's a real
commentary piece as well instead of just
in a what's going on yeah you know so
it's it's like the commentary and
Analysis I think shines a lot more so
I'm very fortunate for what it is and uh
yeah I'm proud of the channel
and I'm proud of you man should be
you've come such a long way since I've
first met you and it's freaking amazing
what you're doing and you're always
always trying to pick your brain about
what's a what's the best idea to cover
what's which thumbnail
there's there's this thing I'll end it
with this there's this thing on a lot of
people call Paul in my circles they call
them the anomaly it's been a common
phrase the anomaly how does he do it how
did classic movie breakdowns how did you
just managed to pull the [__] off
and uh it's always freaking where we go
million views on the aliens video
he's so much of this AI brain himself
that we have this thing on YouTube now
where there's a
uh it's like an AI it doesn't create the
thumbnail but you can pretty much put
like other thumbnails in there and it's
an AI uh decipher that I'll tell you
which one might be better
and it's not like 100 accurate
but sometimes I just I usually drop drop
in like I might have like four
thumbnails and I'll drop them all in and
see which one it picks
and 99 of the time if I just message
Paul and say which one of these thumbs
it is the one the AI went with it like
every single time
that's why he's the anomaly man he's got
that he's got that machine brain that
just knows what to do it's really funny
yeah yeah yeah you know what you're
doing well thanks for that guys we're in
a bit off tangent there but yeah if
you're enjoying the show so far we
really appreciate it uh slowly seeing
the numbers go every single week makes
it makes a world of difference to us
because it you know it's nice to just
sit and hang out and record
conversations and people to actually be
interested in them
um yeah obviously you know we haven't
got everything right we'll hold our
hands up and you know there's lots of
things you might disagree with us on you
might agree with this on the comment box
is the perfect place YouTube invented it
for you guys to interact with us let us
know how you feel go drop those comments
subscribe to the show
um like the videos as well that
massively helps us out we also are on
Spotify we're on Amazon podcasts and
we're on Apple podcasts as well so
wherever you want to listen to us or if
it's just still on YouTube yet thanks a
lot and uh I appreciate your support
again we really do and thanks for
letting us do this thing because you
know that way we are we're gonna get
impacted by the strikes as well well at
some point you know the delays and
content will hear this
um but you know having an audience like
this is like you guys the way you
support us so much on on just us
chatting like this it's it's going to
help us get through it and we really
appreciate it so yeah thanks a lot as
well for that you know you guys even
just by watching the video and clicking
the thumbs up button
it takes two seconds but it honestly it
changes our whole
life and we really appreciate it so yeah
thanks a lot and I hope you guys enjoy
the rest of the week I hope you have as
much fun as I am tomorrow on the
birthday oh so uh yeah whenever you're
watching this thanks for